تطورت العدسات على مدى التاريخ وتتابع
التحسينات عليها وصنفت بانواع على حسب
الاستخدام والحاجه اولها العدسات اليوميه
والتي يتم ارتدائها مره واحده ثم التخلص
منها توفر اعلى مستوى من الراحه فلا تحتاج
للتنظيف او التخزين مناسبه لمن يعانون من
حساسيه العيون العدسات الشهريه والنصف
اسبوعية تستبدل وفقا لجدول زمني منتظم طلب
التنظيف والتخزين عاده متصل مده الموصل
لارتدائها من 8 الى 12 ساعه يوميا العدسات
التي يمكن ارتدائها لفترات طويله بما في
ذلك اثناء النوم وهي مصنوعه من مواد تسمح
بوصول كميه كافيه من الاكسجين الى القرنيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات